Like why writing a business plan
practically here is where the most
important part of your business idea begins
because the idea of ​​reality is that you are
going to start an idea that came
to your mind but there it starts first with
the idea and then  We have to
seek knowledge
in the industry that is
competing if I eat like
Boyacá see me in Las Vegas or in the USA
or if I don't want to be international like
Boyacá see me there and how am I going to
land like  one says where I am going to
fall where I am going to start for them to
see where I am going to walk so
it is also the planning
the business plan that you are going to
write will be like a guide like the
path where you are going to start
first  You have to evaluate if you,
as I repeat, plan from
you forward I am already well
prepared I know the law is denied
I know how I am going to establish the
licenses and how much money  I'm going to
need
someone who is going to help me grow in this
business, that's planning, so it's like
if you start writing the
business plan, it's going to be something that will
show you the way to where you have to
start. It's true, there are many steps, but
we have  to start with one, so that
's the business plan, it's the guide
that will help you start that path, it's
also the work plan for
success because if you don't have
a work strategy it won't
work because the  dream to
reality is something else so I have
the dream of opening the best
beauty salon
but from there I am going to establish it
and that I am going to have how many employees
I am going to have and how much will
the insurance charge me?  to have a good
location when I am going to charge with the
price and if the price that I am going to set is
going to help me sustain the expenses that
also have an income for myself
then this
business idea employee price strategy  or the
culture the culture is how I am going to
answer with the telephone how we are going to
answer when the client has a
complaint how am I going to have when the client
comes and tells him that he does not like my
service that I am going to answer that is the
culture that  You are going to use it, it is part
of the business strategy and it is also
a marketing tool
because if you want to
start a business and you are going to spend 40
thousand 50 thousand dollars to start it and
you only have 10 thousand if it
will help you  to begin
then I say well I'm going to look for a
bank that wants to believe in my story in
my idea I'm going to look for someone to
help me really I'm going to talk to you a
little bit about the lending
capacity your capacity as people is the
that is going to open the doors for the
banks, so it
is very important that we begin to
understand this is the reason for a
true business plan